so fun plus Phoenix the team with the
best dumbest name in eSports are your
reigning League of Legends world
champions
yesterday the curb-stomped g2 and the
worst part was they made it look foreign
it wasn't even a fun stop their
performance has made a lot of people
asked some important questions about the
future of League of Legends namely how
do we stop there from being a fourth
straight 3o grand finals next year so
for anyone who missed it and isn't
afraid of day old spoilers fun plus
Phoenix essentially beat g2 into the
ground for an hour and a half with no
mercy it was so bad that even lwx fvx is
ad carry had to comment on G twos
performance today I don't think it's
because we performed especially well
it's because our opponents didn't really
perform and look you really have to hand
it to FBX they looked untouchable ello
WX didn't even die a single time during
the series that's insane
even G twos owner didn't know what to
say about his team performance it's a
complicated because I'm I'm really sad
I'm really
lot of European fans are heartbroken
jeetu were on the way to the first ever
Grand Slam in a league of Legends
history and their performance all
tournaments made people think that they
were the favourites going into Grand
Finals meanwhile going into Worlds a lot
of people thought that fpx was just a
meme team they were coin flip II they
were inconsistent they played like crazy
people a lot of folks just didn't think
they had what it took to win but FEX
defined those expectations and ran a
clinic on the tournament favourites
again lwx didn't die a single time and
Jim goon only died once at the very end
of the series when it was already over
it was in the most polite terms anyway
this whole thing has got a lot of people
asking what happens next the first
question is the one I've already
mentioned this is the third straight
year Worlds has ended with a three Osam
and that's not great while viewership
was pretty high this year the game
itself was kind of boring and honestly
it feels pretty lame to end such an
exciting tournament on a complete
anticlimax it leads to a few difficult
problems not least of which that it
turns everyone into a goddamn nihilist
and look I get it after watching your
favourite team get absolutely stomped
into the dust it's hard to feel like
there's any hope at all g2 was the best
team the West has ever produced so what
hope does the rest of the world even
have but come on a backbone China had to
get good to beat Korea and stop their
air of dominance any region could do
that take except for na sorry guys
look obviously China is thrilled about
this they are two-time world champions
and their crazy meme team won a
championship honestly I think that means
that all League fans should be happy
about this fpx has an incredible story
between join bees incredible run to
marry his now to the fact that their
coach almost died this year
FEX is kind of an incredible storyline
for League fans so look I have to
imagine that even Chinese fans aren't
super excited about having stayed up for
a stomp no matter how you slice it no
matter who won a300 isn't great it's
just not exciting it's what you never
want to see in eSports so how do we stop
a trio from happening again next year
honestly I don't know some people are
suggesting double elimination brackets
for future worlds and in theory that
could help but I don't think it would
have changed anything this year like are
you saying that splice would have been
able to beat fun plus Phoenix sorry to
splice but I really don't think so at
the end of the day the best team won it
just so happened that the best team
happened to be miles better than the
second-best team that day fbx dominated
the LPL and they have dominated
as well there were doubters after the
group-stage people wondering about their
path here to the finals but they leave
no doubt about it in this series like
they have been for the last three years
and that's the real problem here it just
feels like there's this enormous
insurmountable gap and that's what leads
to that nihilism I talked about but it's
not a riot to fix that it's on all the
other teams to get up to par and
speaking of which what's gonna happen to
g2 they were clearly an incredible team
they were heading towards the grand slam
they were tournament favorites and then
they got annihilated in most games and
most scenes that's a recipe for a break
up a lot of people are saying they
underperform which may be but people are
also saying that fun plus Phoenix just
seemed to be more prepared for g2 than
any other team in the tournament on top
of that some analysts are saying that
fun plus Phoenix just happened to be a
really good counter to g2 weaknesses and
there's there's no weak point there's no
place that you could attack FBX he
couldn't hit him in the draft you
couldn't hit him in the bot lane you
couldn't hit him in the top lane
everyone stood tall on his team and when
you're more than the sum of your parts
and all of your parts look like
superstars on the day that is how you
did this type of 3oh anyway the point is
that hopefully g2 can stick through this
they've had a bad matchup but there's
still an incredible team and them
breaking up would be a really bad thing
for the game they were the team that
pushed everyone further over the course
of the year and they almost did it maybe
they need another year to work out some
of those early game issues they have but
if you're thinking that they should blow
up and start all over
you're insane they're clearly a solid
team but they clearly just need a little
bit of something to push them over the
edge whatever that something is I don't
really know but if I did I'd probably be
making a lot of ocelots of money right
now going be new the tech right he go he
went into what he got married went into
World one it's the married man techie
whatever even if we're women right just
just get yourself a spouse
gender-neutral get yourself a spouse go
home be a family man
Wyn worms yeah you have to go through a
bad time and then get married and that
like resets your whole life and then
you've got the family man power power
marriage easy power of love wins world
every time